بهذا
الصدد المدعيه رسمت صوره قاتمه ولكنها
صوره مغلوطه وصوره مشوه
مشوهه ان الطلب قام بتشويه وصف ما حدث وما
منع المحكمه
منع
ال لا يمكن اثبات ذلك بناء على طلب جهه
واحده اذا
ما اذا كان للماده من الاتفاقيه من النظام
المحكمه له اي معنى وفي الوقت المناسب
ستحدث عن ثلاث جوانب تتعلق بالحقائق
والوقع على الارض المدعيه اما تجاهلتها او
اساءت تمثيلها او عرضها او
لاها ان تكتيكات حماس واستراتيجيتها
العسكريه الثاني جهود اسرائيل للحد من
الاضرار بصفوف المدنيين خلال تنفيذ
عملياتها والامر
الثالث جهود اسرائيل للتعامل مع الصعوبات
الانسانيه في غزه برغم محاولات حماس عرقله
تلك الجهود فيما يتعلق بتكتيكات حماس
العسكريه
واستراتيجياتها من المدهش انه في مرافعات
امس حماس ذكرت فقط بشكل عرضي ومن خلال
الاشاره الى مذبح التي حدثت في الساب من
اكتوبر في اسرائيل الاستماع الى مرافعات
الجهه المدعيه وكان اشارت الى ان حماس
وكانت تتصرف دون وجود عدو ولكن حماس نفسها
التي ذت هجوم السابع من اكتوبر في اسرائيل
هي السلطه الحاكمه في غزه وهي حماس ذاتها
التي بنت او وضعت استراتيجيه عسكريه تقوم
على
تكريس على زرع مقدراتها وقدراتها العسكريه
وعناصرها في صفوف المدنيين الحرب حرب
المدن بالتاكيد ستتسبب
بسقوط ضحايا وتدمير ولكن هذه تفاقمت لانها
كان كانت النتيجه المرغوبه لحركه
حماس في حروب المدن الضحايا في صفوف
المدنيين يمكن ان يكون النتيجه غير
المرغوبه ولكنها المؤلمه لتنفيذ اي عمليات
او اهداف عسكريه ان القانون الانساني
الدولي يقرب بتلك الحقيقه ويوفر اطارا
يوازن فيه بين الضروره العسكريه باعتبارها
والاعتبارات العسكريه ولكن هذه لا تمثل
عملا من اعمال الاباده الجماعيه في هذا
النزاع
الحالي العديد من حالات
القتل تمت على يد حماس افخاخ وشراك تفجرت
وبشكل
عشوائي ادت الى تدمير المباني والمنشات
واكثر من 2000 صاروخ ظلت طريقها وسقطت
داخل اسرائيل ما تسبب بقدر كبير من الضرر
واحدها احد الامثله هو الهجوم او الانفجار
في مبنى المستشفى الاهلي ادعت حماس بان
قوات الدفاع الاسرائيلي هي التي هاجمت
المستشفى
وعناوين الصحف سرعت الى تاكيد ذلك الزعم
ولكن المعلومات الاستخباريه من قبل وكالات
امريكيه وغيرها اكدت وبشكل مستقل انفجار
جاء
جراء فشل صاروخ اطلق من داخل غزه وليس كما
ادعت حماس
بانه ذنب جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي او بسبب
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان الاضرار تلحق
بالمدنيين هي احدى الحقائق التي تحدثت
عنها جنوب افريقيا باعتبارها دليلا على
الاباده الجمعيه ولكنها لم تشر الى
الاستخدام الواسع النطاق للمباني والمرافق
المدنيه لاغراض عسكريه المنازل والمدارس
والمساجد ومرافق ومنشات الامم المتحده
والملاجئ كلها اسيء استخدامها لاغراض
عسكريه من قبل حماس بما في ذلك مواقع
لاطلاق الصواريخ المئات من
مئات الكيلومترات من الانفاق التي شقتها
حماس هذه تسببت بسقوط وانهيار عديد
المباني وكما هو ظاهر امامكم هذا صاروخ
على وشك الاطلاق وترون الحفره في منزل
مدني لاخفاء هذا الصاروخ واطلاقه من هناك
هنا في هذه الصوره ترون
قذائف واكتشفت تحت في غرفه نوم لاحد
الاطفال هنا
صاروخ يطلق من
مدرسه وموقع الاطلاق هو محاط باللون
الاحمر بالدائره الحمراء هنا ترون اطلاقا
لصاروخ من مدرسه تابعه للامم المتحده
وترون رمز الامم المتحده يو ان على سطح
تلك المدرسه وفي هذه الصوره كما ترون
صارو منصفات اطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى
مخفات داخل هذه داخل هذا هذه المدرسه وهذا
جزء من نفق طوله 4 كيلومترات قريب من
الحدود
الاسرائيليه البنى التحتيه في غزه تعرضت
لضرر كبير ودمار كبير خلال هذا النزاع
ولكن جنوب افريقيا عليه تحاول ان تدفع
المحكمه للاعتقاد بان اسرائيل وبشكل متعمد
وبشكل غير قانوني تدمر المنازل والبيوت
دون سبب
ولكن هذا جاء نتيجه لافعال حماس واعمالها
وهذا لا يعد دليلا على الاباده الجماعيه
جنوب افريقيا ايضا زعمت بان اسرائيل شنت
هجوما على المنظومه الصحيه في غزه ولكن ما
تجاه ما فشلت جنوب افريقيا في عرضه امام
المحكمه هو الادله الدامغه بشان استخدام
حماس لتلك
المستشفيات مقتل حماس لجوا الى مستشفى
الرنتيسي في السابع من اكتوبر
وبحوزتهم رهائن اسرائيليين تم اخفائهم في
قبو ذلك المستشفى وفي الشريحه التي
ساعرضها سترون مقاتلون يدخلون مستشفى احد
المستشفيات
يحملون ار بي جي او قاذف صواريخ ار بي جي
وفي مستشفى الشفاء اكبر
مستشفيات نفذت حماس عمليات من مناطق قريبه
من ذلك المستشفى هنا ترون فتحه لنفق يمتد
على مدى مئات الامتار تحت
المستشفى هنا في هذه الصور ترون الاسلحه
التي تم العثور في اجنحه مختلفه في ذلك
المستشفى وفي هذه الصوره
ايضا كاميرات
الكاميرات اظهرت مقاتل حماس في اروقه
المستشفى اكثر من 200 مقاتل كانوا مختبئين
في احد المستشفيات وسلموا انفسهم للجيش
وهنا ترون سلاحا عثرت عليه قوات الجيش
داخل اجهزه الخداج في المستشفيات وعدد
واثبتت الادله ان هنالك عديد العاملين في
المستشفيات من صفوف حماس وفي جبال قوات
حماس نفذت عملياتها من ذلك المستشفى الى
ان وصلت اليه قوات الجيش قوات الجيش
اكتشفت
اكتشفت جثث خمسه رهائن مختطفين في انفاق
والقائمه تطول
وتطول في كل
مستشفى فتشه الجيش وجدوا فيه ادله على
استخدامات عسكريه من قبل حماس اسرائيل
تدرك تماما وانه بسبب استخدام حماس ل
المستشفيات كدروع لعملياتها العسكريه وهذا
يعد انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الانساني
الدولي فان المرضى والطواقم
الطبيه في خطر وبالتالي قامت اسرائيل
بالتواصل مع كل المستشفيات فيما يتعلق
باعاده نقل المرضى والمصابين الى مناطق
امنه المستشفيات لم يتم قصفها ولكن الجيش
ارسل جنودا من اجل البحث البحث عن مرافق
عسكريه وتدميرها الانفاق التي تم حفرها
تحت المبنى الرئيس الرئيس في مستشفى
الشفاء تم تفجيره دون الحاق اي ضرر في
المستشفى وانسحبت قوات الجيش بعد ذلك نعم
الدمار والضرر حدث نتيجه لاعمال القتال في
في محيط المستشفيات احيانا من خلال اطلاق
النار من قبل الجيش واحيانا من قبل حماس
ولكن دائما وكن نتيجه مباشره
لاساليب حماس العسكريه
المروعه اسرائيل نشرت ادله كثيره بشان
استخدام حماس لمرافق مدنيه وهذا يعد
انتهاكا صارخا
وجلبت صحفيين ليروا بم اعينهم
وكذلك كل ذلك لم
يتم ذكره في الطلب المدعيه وصفت النتائج
وطلبت من
المحكمه
[موسيقى]
ان تثبت نيه خبيثه من قبل
اسرائيل استراتيجيه حماس لتحويل
المستشفيات
الى معسكرات ارهابيه هذا ما اخفقت جنوب
افريقيا
فيان على
ذكره ما اخفقت الجه في اعلام المحكمه بشان
ازدراء حماس لحياه الفلسطينيين وقامت
باطلاق صواريخ بشكل متعمل من تلك المناطق
وحولت مناطق الاغاثه الى مناطق حرب
وصراع امامكم هنا مثال على موقع اطلاق
صواريخ قريب من احدى المناطق الانسانيه او
التي خصصت
للغايات الغايات الانسانيه وتم تكبير تلك
الصوره في الشريحه التاليه ترون ادله على
صاروخ تم اطلاقه من في محيط محطه تحليه
مياه في غزه والان اود ان اتحدث عن القضيه
الثانيه جهود اسرائيل للحد من الاذى في
صفوف المدنيين هنا مره
اخرى
المدعيه نقلت صوره
[موسيقى]
بماد في
المنشات وهذا زعم
صارخ بعيد كل البعد عن الاطار القانوني
للقانون الانسان الدولي
ان اخلاء
المدنيين هو احد التدابير وفقا للقانون
الانسان الدولي الذي يهدف الى حمايه
المدنيين من اعمال القتال الحاليه وعمليات
الاخلاء والجلاء يمكن ان ترقى الى واجب
ومسؤوليه يتعين على اطراف ان تقوم بها
تجاه المدنيين ولكن هذا العمل ينطوي على
معاناه وغيرها لكن من الافضل
عدم